what's up guys I'm Lisa Foyle's here
again on analog the show that aims to
quadruple your gaming library with more
games like the ones you already love
today it's all about Cartman butters
Kyle Stan and the beautiful princess
Kenny South Park the stick of truth
finally arrived in April of this year
for 360 ps3 and pc and it was well worth
away I will say but if you've beaten it
already and you want more of the same we
have got you covered here are games
similar to the stick of truth and a kink
that and the King wishes to be amused
the moment I entered into my first
altercation as the new kid in South Park
under the ever sarcastic wing of Eric
Cartman I thought a paper mario these
two games are very similar for several
reasons let's start with combat stick of
truth and paper mario share the same DNA
combat is turn-based with time
attributes you select the thing you want
to punch and then you walk over and
punch it attack at just the right time
when button prompted for critical hits
not only does Paper Mario share combat
mechanics the Mario & Luigi games for
GBA and DS do too for that matter
but it also gives you that same front
view third-person perspective with flat
2d graphics hence the name Paper Mario
the whole point of stick of truth' was
to give it the art style and colorful
vibrance of the TV series so it felt
like you were playing an episode of the
show Paper Mario is the same bright
charming graphics with flat paper
characters who roam around in
environments that certainly don't feel
flat it's an awesome mix of 2d and 3d
Paper Mario like stick of truth is a
light RPG it's simplistic and deals in
low numbers you have 50 hit points
instead of 5000 for example and lastly
my favorite similarity and stick of
truth you're hunting for the stick of
truth and in Paper Mario you're after
the star rod of power basically the same
thing guys come on
stick of truth is rot with dirty jokes
adult themes and butt probes I cannot
say that with a straight face but
underneath the toilet humor and the
crude language the game is really about
being a kid it's you and your friends
dressing up in costumes and roaming the
neighborhood on your epic quest well
same thing with costume quest
it's Halloween you and your sibling you
select to be either the brother or
sister
Tromp through the neighborhood and your
costumes in search of candy but a creepy
goblin snatches your sibling and the
adventure to save them and find out what
the heck is happening begins South Park
the game and the TV show thrives by
having adult themes that are tempered by
a kid's interpretation kids see things
differently in costume quest recognizes
that in combat same combat as stick of
truth' turn-based with timed attacks but
once you enter the battle arena your
cardboard robot costume morphs into a
giant mech with real magic powers each
costume transforms radically once battle
begins and they each have different
attacks
it's imagination come to life sort of
like butters is alter-ego professor
chaos costume quest keeps track of the
friends you make similar to stick of
truths in game Facebook page and sadly
they also share a short length both
games can be beaten in about 10 to 15
hours but they're totally worth it trust
me ok ok
enough childish games if you like stick
of truth for the clever comedy wacky
situations and hilarious details then
you need to play earthbound this one was
easy Trey Parker and Matt Stone even
cited earthbound as inspiration for
stick of truth they wanted an RPG that
made you feel like just a kid playing a
game where a bunch of crazy stuff
happens earth bound gets the crazy right
just because it makes you feel like a
kid does not mean it's kid ish this game
is hilarious yes it's another turn-based
RPG based off the original Dragon Quest
model but its characters dialogue and
the ability to make fun of itself has
made this a cult classic you fight
enemies like the spiteful crow annoying
old party man urban zombie and the
clumsy robot you'll notice insane
attention to detail as you roam around
with your buddies this is a game that
must be played slowly wackiness aside
earthbound is
a really great game that connects with
you on an emotional level especially at
the end it's unexpected but totally
works
so if you want a real-life actual quest
try getting your hands on an original
Super Nintendo cartridge of earthbound
or just make it easy on yourself and
play it on the Wii U Virtual Console
because trust me it is impossible to
find leave a comment with games you
think are similar to South Park stick of
truth and you know any creepy back
alleyways you know of where people can
buy earthbound
hit me up on Twitter at Lisa Foyle's and
I will see you next week for another
episode of analog